WE EXPLAIN HOW THEY FIND MISERY
IN AMERICA'S HAPPINESS.
ANOTHER PATHETIC CLOWN SHOW ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
THE PARTY OF ABORTION ON DEMAND
SCARES MORE ABOUT THE CHILDREN
THEN YOU HEARTLESS SOULLESS
REPUBLICANS.
>> DO YOU NOT CARE.
BECAUSE THESE CHILDREN DON'T
LOOK LIKE CHILDREN THAT ARE
AROUND YOU?
HAVE YOU EVER HELD A DECEASED
CHILD IN YOUR ARMS?
>> FIRST OF ALL YOUR COMMENTS
ARE DISGUSTING.
I HAVE SERVED MY COUNTRY FOR 35
YEARS.
I HELD A BOY 5 YEARS OLD IN MY
ARMS.
I KNELT DOWN AND SAID A PRAYER
FOR HIM.
I HAD A FIVE-YEAR-OLD SON AT THE
TIME.
FOR YOU TO INSULT BY INTEGRITY
AND MY LOVE FOR THE COUNTRY AND
CHILDREN, THAT'S WHY THIS WHOLE
THING NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
>> I WANTED TO GIVE HIM A
STANDING "VATION
STANDING OVATION ALL DAY LONG.
WHAT TOM IS POINTING OUT THE
CONGRESSMAN UP THERE AND THE
REST REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE CRAZY
CONCEPT KNOWN AS THE RULE OF
LAW.
>> YOU'RE THE AUTHOR OF THE
FAMILY SEPARATION POLICY.
>> I'M NOT THE AUTHOR OF THE
MEMO.
>> YOU SIGNED THE MEMO.
>> YES.
>> YOU RECOMMENDED FAMILY
SEPARATION.
>> I RECOMMENDED ZERO TOLERANCE.
IT'S THE SAME IF I AM ARRESTPUGH
WITH A CHILD IN THE CAR I WILL
BE SEPARATED.
>> WITH ALL DO RESPECT LEGAL --
IS NOT BREAKING THE LAW.
>> IF YOU COME THROUGH THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY -- -
>> IT'S LEGAL.
>> YOU DO IT THE LEGAL WAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS MADE THAT
CLEAR.
>> OKAY.
>> Laura: OOPS.
THREE OF THE FOUR PROGRESSIVE IT
GIRLS.
CONJURING UP EMOTION AND
PASSION, THEY READ FROM THE DOG
EARED SCRIPT THAT DEMONIZES
BORDER PATROL AND ICE AND
FORGETS ABOUT DULY PASSED LAWS
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
AT A CERTAIN POINT FORMER ACTING
ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN HAD JUST
ABOUT ENOUGH.
>> AS A 34-YEAR-OLD VETERAN OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S SHOCKING.
SHOCKING TO SEE THE CONSTANT
ATTACKS AGAINST THOSE PUTTING
THEIR OWN SAFETY AT RISK TO
DEFEND THIS NATION.
YOU SEE NEWS REPORTS THEY'RE
NAZIS, WHITE SUPREMACIST.
THEY ABUSE WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
ICE AGENTS AND BORDER PATROL
AGENTS ARE PARENTS TOO.
THIS AFFECTS THEM DEEPLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
HAVE YOU EVER WALKED UP TO ONE
AND THANKED THEM FOR HELPING
THEIR NATION.
I HAVE.
>> Laura: GAME SET.
MATCH.
THE ONLY BORDER, THE NEW AND
RADICALIZED DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BELIEVES IN NOW ARE THOSE AROUND
ABORTION CLINICS KEEPING
SIDEWALK COUNSELORS AWAY FROM
VULNERABLE WOMEN.
WHEN HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
EXPRESSED A BIT OF EMPATHY
TOWARDS THE THOUSANDS OF VICTIMS
COMMITTING CRIMES OF ILLEGAL I
IMMIGRANTS.
SUCH AS CORY WHO WAS KILLED LAST
MONTH WHEN A ILLEGAL DROVE DRUNK
AND RAN HIM OVER.
HIS FAMILY IS SEPARATED FROM HIM
FOR EVER.
IT'S AOC OR ANY KNOWN DEMOCRAT
SHED A TEAR FOR THESE TRAGEDIES,
EVER?
NOT THAT I HAVE SEEN.
INSTEAD THEY WOULD RATHER PAINT
AMERICA AS A PLACE FOR ALL
IMMIGRANTS, GOOD AND DESERVING
DESPITE THE LAWS THEY VIOLATE
AND COURT ORDERS THEY BRAZENLY
IGNORE.
>> OUR GOVERNMENT AT THE HANDS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
EXHIBITED A IN COMPETENCE AND
CRUELTY CREATING A HUMAN RIGHTS
CRISIS IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> THEY HAVE ACCUSED THOSE
WORKING TO STOP THIS, BORDER
AGENTS, OF CREATING A CULTURE OF
CRUELTY.
>> THERE IS NO NEED TO ARREST
INNOCENT PEOPLE AND TREAT THEM
NO DIFFERENT THEN CRIMINALS
PURSUING THEIR BASIC HUMAN
NIGHTS.
>> CALLING THESE CONCENTRATION
STYLE CAMPS THAT'S DOESN'T STOP
THE PROBLEM.
>> Laura: -- IS BROKEN AND
ILLEGITIMATE, THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
SO THE LAW THAT'S DEMOCRATS
DON'T LIKE, THEY TOO ARE
ILLEGITIMATE.
JOINING ME NOW A GROUP FOR MORE.
THIS HEARING WAS QUITE SOMETHING
TODAY.
WE HAD TOM HOLMAN WHO HAS PUT ON
A UNIFORM SERVING THE COUNTRY
FOR THREE DECADES.
HE'S TICKED OFF AND I THINK
RIGHTFULLY SO ABOUT THE STKE
MONNIZATION OF MEN AND WOMEN OF
BORDER PATROL.
50% WHO ARE HISPANIC AMERICANS.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT HE SAID.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, I HEAR MR. HOLMAN
TALK ABOUT HIMSELF AND HOW HE
FEELS AND THE LAWS BROKEN.
I DON'T HEAR HIM SAYING ANYTHING
ABOUT THE FAMILIES, CHILDREN,
MOTHERS.
WE RECENTLY HEARD ABOUT A CHILD,
A BUY BEE, MARIA I THINK WAS HER
NAME WHO DIED IN THE CUSTODY OF
IMMIGRATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MR. HOMAN
TALK ABOUT --
>> Laura: YOU'RE UPSET HE DOES
HAVEN'T THE EMOTION.
>> HE HAS THE EMOTION BUT DIRECT
THAT EMOTION TO THE CHILDREN.
NOT TALKING  ABOUT ADULTS AND
CRIMINALS.
HE'S CONTINUING TO TALK ABOUT
ICE PATROL AGENTS --
>> Laura: THINK HE'S IN A
SITUATION IS W. A CRYING CHILD
HE DOES THE CARE.
I THINK HE CARES.
>> Laura: ALL CARE.
WERE BROUGHT WHICHWHOMWE>> YO
YOUWE'RE PEOPLE AND USED --
>> Laura: I WAS DOWN IN PUGH EL
RIO IN EAGLE PASS, END OF APRIL,
EARLY MAY.
I SAW WAS APPALLING.
IS SOME OF THE VIDEO.
SEE THE BORDER PATROL BOAT.
JUMP WITH A PULL TOY OR A BLOW
UP INTER TUBE.
KNOW OUR BORDER PATROL ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO PICK THEM UP
WELL.
ALWAYS RESCUE THEM.
WHAT WE DO.
WHO WE ARE.
DON'T LET PEOPLE DROWNED.
NOT WHAT WE DO.
COUNTRIES MAY, WE DON'T DO
THAT.
DEMOCRATS TODAY, NO WE DON'T
PICK THEM UP.
WANT THEM TO SUFFER.
NOT WHAT I SAW THERE.
SAW WE NEED TO WANT FORM THE
SYSTEM FOR PEOPLE TO BE SAFE
APPLYING FOR ASYLUM AND NOT
ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN BY BRINGING THEM
THOUSANDS OF MILES FROM THEIR
HOMETOWN.
REACTION TODAY?
I THINK TOM HOMAN SHOULD OF
WALKED OUT.
WHAT I WOULD OF DONE.
PEOPLE MAKING THESE COMMENTS.
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE.
IDIOTIC.
OF THE COMMENTS ARE JUST
STUPID.
MEN AND WOMEN OF BORDER PATROL
AND ICE GO OUT EVERY DAY PUTTING
THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE TO
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY THEY ARE VIOLATING
FEDERAL LAW.
YOU DON'T WANT THOSE KIDS
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
YOU DON'T WANT THE KIDS TAKEN
AWAY, THEN DON'T COME INTO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT ASYLUM.
FOR ASYLUM APPROPRIATELY.
THE GUIDEFRONT OF THE LAW.
TRY TO BREAK THE LAW COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY, AND THEN
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE OUT COME OF
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
>> Laura: AS WE TALKED ABOUT
MANY TIMES, CONGRESSMAN DUFFY,
THE TRIP UP HERE IS A BAD TRIP.
ARE SLEEPING IN FIELDS,
CEMENT, BENCHES, FLOORS,
OCCASIONALLY SOMEONE TAKES THEM
IN AND THEY SLEEP ON A MAT
SOMEWHERE.
NOT LIKE IT'S THE RITZ ON THE
WAY UP FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
ARE IN TRUCKS, BUSES.
IDEA THAT, THAT THEY COME TO
THE UNITED STATES AND IT'S ALL
TERRIBLE, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S BAD, OVER CROWDED.
COME ON.
THE ASYLUM REFORM HAS TO HAPPEN.
A LOT OF THEM CROSS, CONGRESSMAN
DUFFY, AND THEY CROSS
TECHNICALLY FOLLOWING THE LAW.
WHAT BERNIE JUST SAID IT'S NOT
QUITE RIGHT.
WHAT GUNTHER SAID THEY'RE
PURSUING THE LEGAL PROCESS.
THE LEGAL PROCESS IS SCREWED UP.
>> THEY SHOULD APPLY FOR ASYLUM
IN THE FIRST SAFE COUNTRY THEY
GET TO.
WHAT BURNS MY BACKSIDE, I HEAR
DEMOCRATS SHED TEARS WHAT HAD IS
HAPPENING IN THE DETENTION
CENTERS, WE SHOULD IMPROVE THEM,
BUT YES THEY CAME ACROSS THE
DESSERT WITH MEXICAN DRUG
CARTELS.
SHED A TEAR FOR THE ANGEL MOM
WHOSE DON'T HUG THEIR CHILDREN
ANY LONGER, OR THE CHILDREN
RAPED ACROSS THE DESERTS FROM
DRUG CARTELS, OR THOSE LOSING
LIVES MURDERED BY AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT, OR GONZALES WHO HAD
HIS THREAT CUT FROM THE DRUG
CARTEL AND HIS SON WAS FOUND
HUGGING HIM DEAD IN THE DESERT.
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES.
IF NOT SPEND THE $4.6 BILLION TO
THE BORDER PATROL TO TAKE OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE DETENTION CENTERS.
WHEN YOU DON'T VOTE FOR THE
MONEY AND CRY FOR IT, GIVE ME A
BREAK.
>> Laura: GUNTHER, QUICKLY.
THEN WE HAVE TO BRING EVERYONE
TO THE BIG PROTEST TO THE.
WE HAVE A INTERESTING REPORT.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND A
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY SAYS THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM COME
THROUGH THE BOARDER AND STAY IN
MEXICO INSTEAD OF THE UNITED
STATES THIS.
IS A COUNTRY THAT PROTECTS
REFUGEES.
PROTECTS THOSE WHO CAN'T PROTECT
THEMSELVES PHR-FPLT DUFFY, YOU
CAN'T COMPARE THE UNITED STATES
AND MEXICO AS A SAFE COUNTRY.
THAT'S BE RIGHT.
>> WE HAVE SAID MEXICO IS A SAFE
PLACE.
>> IF YOU GET MURDERED OR
HURT --
>> MEXICO IS NOT THE ANSWER.
MEXICO I AM NOT STAYING IN
COMING TO THE UNITED STATES.
>> YOU MAKE MY POINT.
IT'S A DANGEROUS POINT.
DON'T SAY IT'S HORRIFIC IF A
DETENTION CENTER.
THEY'RE COMING ACROSS THE
DESSERT WITH DRUG CARTELS.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO BRING
EVERYONE TO WHAT IS HAPPENING
TONIGHT.
IMMIGRATION PROTESTS ARE
HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE WENT TO ONE OUTSIDE OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED.
>> NOBODY IS BEING MURDERED ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> CHILDREN HAVE DIED.
>> HOW IS THIS THE SAME.
>> YOU SEPARATE CHILDREN FROM
THE PARENTS.
>> WHAT MAKES THEM A
CONCENTRATION CAMP.
>> A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
CONCENTRATED TOGETHER.
>> THE THE CONDITION THAT'S
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING ENFORCED
AND CONCENTRATED WITH.
IT'S INHUMAN.
I'M NOT SAYING THEY SHOULD BE
LET OUT.
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED WITH
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS.
LOOK AROUND.
>> Laura: WELL, WE KNOW GUNTHER
THE BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS WE WERE
ABLE TO AFFORD THEM IS LIMITED
BY THE RESOURCES AT THE BORDER.
I WAS AT ONE OF THE SMALLER
BORDER CROSSINGS, DEL RIO, IT
WAS TEAMING THIS.
IS ALL WE HAVE THEY SAID.
WHAT DO THEY WANT CHILDREN JUST
ROAMING THE STREETS, RELEASE
THEM.
THEY'RE BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE.
YOU WOULDN'T JUST HAVE THEM
RELEASE THEM INTO THE STREETS,
WOULD YOU?
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
CHILDREN GETTING SICK AT THESE
CENTERS.
>> SOME ARE SICK WHEN THEY COME.
THEN WE SEE A SPREAD AS WE HEARD
FROM DR. DREW, IT'S ALL
THROUGHOUT DIFFERENT CITIES IN
THE UNITED STATES DISEASES WE
THOUGHT SE SEE RAT INDICATED.
>> AND ONE HAS DIED SO WE STOP
IT.
>>
.>
>> Laura: BERNIE, CLOSE IT OUT.
WHAT DO WE MAKE OF THIS.
>>
'S RANRIKER'S ISLAND.
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S NOT AN EASY
JOB OR AN EASY TASK.
WITH THE NUMBERS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY AND THE NUMBERS THEY
HAVE TO PROCESS WE NEED MORE A
SOURCES OR THEY HAVE TO STOP IT.
PERIOD.
>> Laura: ONE WE HAVE TO STOP
IT, CONGRESSMAN DUFFY, THIS
WOULD REQUIRE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS WORKING TOGETHER.
THAT WOULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THERE IS NO SIGN THAT IS GOING
TO HAPPEN.
REAL QUICK.
>> IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
DEMOCRATS LIKE THIS CRISIS.
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS YOU CAN
CLOSE IT IN 15 MINUTES.
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES AND SEND THE
MONTE AND THIS IS OVER.
DEMOCRATS ARE UNWILLING TO DO
THIS AND THE CRISIS CONTINUES.
WOULDN'T OF IT BEEN NICE IF THEY
RECOGNIZED THIS SIX MONTHS AGO